Let's first understand what dilute and
concentrated mean generally.
the most important thing about these terms is that they are relative.
What do I mean by relative?
Here are two beakers on the screen.
One on the left, and one on the right.
And both have 100 ml of some colorless solvent.
Now in the beaker on the left, I add 20 ml of some red solute.
And on the right, I add 50 ml of the same red solute.
In this case, we say that the solution on the right is concentrated.
And the one on the left is dilute.
We are looking at these two relative to each other
And you can see, that the concentrated solution is more red in color
as compared to the dilute one.
This is stronger we can say
Let me give you another example
We take two empty beakers again
both with 100ml of some solution
The first beaker has 20 ml of some solute
and 80 ml of solvent
and the second one has 25 ml of solute
and 75 ml of solvent
Which solution is more concentrated according to you?
yes it's the second one
because the proportion of solute is more, in the second beaker
now that you know what dilute and concentrated mean
let's move on to understanding what
concentrated acids and bases are
in cases of acids
water is considered to be a solvent and the acid added
to the water is the solute. So we have
one beaker on the screen here with some water and we add
acid to it
as the amount of acid I'm adding to the beaker is
increasing
the solution is getting more and more concentrated
now let me ask you an interesting question!
When I'm mixing acid and water, should we
add water to the acid, or should we add acid to the water?
To know the answer, what we should know is that
the process of dissolving an acid or base in water is
highly exothermic, which means
a lot of heat is generated
Now if we add water to the acid, the heated generated may
cause the mixture to splash out, which may cause severe burns
And the glass container which contains the solution
may also crack due to excessive heating
You would probably argue that the same would happen
when acid is added to the water, right?
Not really, and let me explain why
When we add acid to the water, the reaction will still be exothermic
But the water is a very good absorber of heat
Yes, unlike the acid the water
absorbs the heat
And that is why adding acid to water is better than
doing it the other way around. But remember,
the acid must be added very slowly, drop by drop
and we should constantly stir the solution
because if we add a lot of acid directly to water
the heat generated will be so large that even
water will not be able to absorb the heat.